مرحبا بكم في هذه النافذه للتحليل العسكري
اذا لمجريات حرب اسرائيل على قطاع غزه
نرحب باللواء فاز الدويري وكذلك سلام خضر
سلام سنبدا معك ولكن قبل ذلك سياده اللواء
اريد فقط ان اشير الى ما اعلن عن الاجهاز
على 15 جنديا اسرائيليا هذه نقطه سنعود
للحديث عنها ولكن نبدا معك سلام اذا
وملفته هذه المعارك المحتدم في شمال غزه
بالضبط عثمان خاصه وان وزير الدفاع سبق
وان قال قبل ثلاثه اسابيع بان القدرات
العسكريه للمقاومه في شمال القطاع انتهت
اذا سنتوجه مباشره الى شمال القطاع غزه
اللافت قبل اقل من ساعه ونصف من الان
اعلنت كتائب القسام انها استهدفت تجمعا
لجنود اسرائيليين في جنوب مدينه غزه وانها
اجهزت على 15 جنديا اسرائيليا من قوات
الاحتلال يتمركزون جنوب المدينه كان سبق
هذا
الاعلان اعلانات متتاليه من شهود عيان ومن
مراسل قناه الجزيره انس الشريف قال بان
قوات الاحتلال نفذت انسحابات واعاده تموضع
واسعه النطاق من المناطق الشماليه في قطاع
غزه لياتي هذا التطور
الابرز في الخريطه خريطه القتال في قطاع
غزه لماذا الابرز ما نعرفه من التحركات
الاسرائيليه بان قو الاحتلال تمركزت خلال
الايام القليله الماضيه عند الشارع رقم 10
ونقلت عدد كبير من الياتها الى هذه النقاط
الشارع رقم 10 الذي يقع جنوب المنطقه
الشماليه في قطاع غزه تمركز الاليات عند
الشارع رقم 10 اتاح لقوات الاحتلال شن
عمليات توغر باتجاه المناطق الاكثر قربا
من قلب مدينه غزه شارع 13 باتجاه تل
الهواء وكان هناك توغل نحو شارع الصناعه
ايضا لتترك الاشتباكات الى حد بعيد في
منطقه جغرافيه لا تتجاوز مساحتها بشكل
كامل كيلومتر مربع واحد في هذا الكيلومتر
المربع الواحد تشهد هذه المنطقه قتالا
مباشرا قتالا من المسافه صفر وهذا هو
مصطلح عسكري القتال من المسافه صفر اي
فعليا غياب المسافه الجغرافيه واسعه
النطاق اي ان ال المقاتلين يستخدمون اسلحه
رشاشه في هذا القتال اليوم شاهدنا عده
فيديوهات من هذه المنطقه سواء لكتائب
القسام او لسرايا القدس راينا فيها
المقاومين وراينا فيها بندقيات المقاومين
رايناهم يطلقون النار باتجاه تجمعات جنود
اسرائيليين في هذه البقعه الجغرافيه
الكيلومتر الواحد وايضا الى امتدادات ما
دون هذا الكيلومتر حيث تتمركز القوات
والاليات الاكثر الاكثر عددا والاكثر
تجهيزا لانه القتال في هذه المنطقه يحتم
بالفعل وجود قوات مسانده للجنود وتكون
متمركزه اساسا في الشارع رقم 10 وقد يكون
هناك نقاط اسناد اكثر قربا من حيث يشتبك
الطرف
المقاومون وقوات الاحتلال هذه ستحتاج الى
تفسير سن نستمع اليه مع اللواء الدويري
وعثمان ولكن قبل الانتقال الى التحليل
والقراءه نعود الى منطقه خان يونس العوده
الى خان يونس ضروريه جدا لانها المنطقه
الاساسيه التي يفترض ان تشهد القتال
الاعنف مدينه خان يونس كانت تقول عنها
القوات الاسرائيليه بانها المعقل الاساسي
لكتاب خصان بان القاده يتمركزون فيها
وبانهم يشتبهون بوجود المحتجزين في
خانيونس نفذت وتنفذ قوات الاحتلال عده
عمليات اعاده تموضع تنقل جنودا من مخيم
خانيونس او معسكر خانيونس كما يسمى محليا
الى شارع الامل في محاوله لاختراق المناطق
الشماليه والمناطق الشرقيه داخل مدينه
خانيونس التي لم تدخل اليها بعد القوات
الاسرائ بمعنى عندما نتحدث عن المستشفيين
الرئيسيين في مدينه خانيونس الامل ومستشفى
ناصر لا تزال هاتان المناطق خارج نطاق
سيطره القوات الاسرائيليه والتوغل
الاسرائيلي النقطه الاخيره سبق للقوات
الاسرائيليه ان اعلنت ان المواصي يمكن ان
يتوجه اليها السكان من المدنيين اليوم
الافاده الميدانيه من مراسلي الجزيره اي
شخص مدني يتحرك باتجاه المواصي يتم قتله
وقنصه من قبل قوات الاحتلال سريعا هذه
التطورات القراءه معك عثمان واللواء
الدويري نعم وكما بدات انت من الشمال ايضا
سلام سنبدا من الشمال سياده اللواء كيف
تقيم ما يحدث في شمال غزه الان يعني
المركه الشمال تحولت الى المرحله الثالثه
بناء على حديث وزير الدفاع الكيان
الاسرائيلي منذ ثلاثه اسابيع بالامس كان
هناك انسحاب مع الضوء الا وكان انسحابا
مفاجئا القوات كانت موجوده مع الضوء الاول
كانت قد تراجعت هذه القوات لكن القوات
التي انسحبت تعود الى الفرقه
162 كان في الاصل اسمحلي اسمح لي سي الواء
فقط نشاهد هذه الصور للرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن وهذا في
استقبال الجثامين الثلاثه ل الجنود
الامريكيين الذين قتلوا في الاردن قبل نحو
اربعه ايام طبعا هناك حديث عن ان الولايات
المتحده سوف سترد ولكن ليس واضحا اين
بالضبط وان كان الحديث عن انها سترد في
اكثر من
موقع بعد قليل اذا بعد قليل سوف نتابع هذه
القصه مع جمال ريان ولكن نعود نحن الى
ال النافذه العسكريه بعد لحظات ولكن نشاهد
الان هذه الصور التي تاتينا من الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه كما اشرت هذا هو الرئيس
بايدن برفقه زوجته وعدد من كبار الضباط
وهم في استقبال جثامين الجنود الامريكيين
الثلاثه الذين قتلوا في الاردن قبل اربعه
ايام هذه الصور اذا هي قبل قليل
للرئيس
الامريكي والحديث عن رد امريكي قريب في
اكثر من موقع وهو
يشارك في استقبال هذه الجثامين
الان هذا الهجوم كان في شمال شرق الاردن
الاحد
الماضي
واكبت هذا الامر نقاشات موزعه موسعه في
البيت الابيض وفي البنتاجون في وزاره
الدفاع وبين كبار القاده السياسيين
والعسكريين نشاهد في الصوره هنا لويد
اوستن وزير الدفاع الامريكي والحديث هنا
عن طبيعه الرد الامريكي وان ما كان سوف
يؤدي الى توسعه الصراع ام لا وطبعا وسط
الحديث ايضا عن ضروره ان يكون هناك رد ما
يقال انه بات
قريبا وزير الدفاع الامريكي لويد اوستن
يرا يشارك في مراسم هذا الاستقبال وكان
طبعا قد
تحدث عن وضعه الصحي الذي مر به وكيف انه
غاب بعض الوقت واعتذر للشعب الامريكي
والرئيس الامريكي ايضا عن عدم اخباره
مبكرا بحالته الصحيه ولكن هو يقول ان هذه
حاله من الممكن علاجها وهي يعني منتشره
على اي حال كما قلت سوف نتابع مع جمال
ريان بعد قليل الحديث عن هذه
الجزئيه
نتابع هذا الموضوع لاحقا ولكن نعود الى
التحليل العسكري لما يحدث في غزه الان مع
اللواء الدويري قبل ان اقاطعك لنشاهد هذه
الصور كنا نتحدث عن الوضع في الشمال الان
الوضع في الشمال كما قلت لك صباح امس كان
هناك انسحاب مفاجئ
لق التي تعود الى الفرقه
162 لا يوجد خبر اكيد لانه نحتاج الى صور
اقمار صناعيه حتى نتحقق من اماكن وجودها
لكن يبدو ان جل هذه القوات انسحب الى غلاف
غزه وابقى على قوات بسيطه الان العمليات
هي في الجنوب الغربي من مدينه غزه وهناك
العديد من التقارير اشارت بانه بقي لوائين
في هذه المنطقه اذا سمحت لي قبل نتحدث عن
الجنوب ايض ايضا المعارك كانت محتدمه في
الشمال والحديث عن ان كتائب القسام قبل
قليل فقط تقول اجهزت على 15 جندي انا
اتحدث عن جنوب غرب مدينه غزه في القاطع
الشمالي الجنوب خانيونس ل سنتحدث عن جنوب
الشمال دعنا نقول انا اتحدث عن القاطع
الشمالي في جنوب غرب مدينه غزه عند تل
الهواء والشيخ عجلين والرمال الجنوبي هذه
المنطقه القوات التي دخلتها ليست من
القوات التي انسحبت هذه هناك قوات موجوده
في وادي غزه وموجوده من فتره طويله
وبالتالي كانت تتواجد من المنطقه من جحر
الديك الى جسر وادي غزه وحتى الرشيد دخلت
هذه
القوات تدخلها كان مختلف متباين من حيث
المسافات واذا عدنا للايام السابقه نجد ان
الشيخ عجلين صدر منه فيديوهات تل الهواء
صدر منه فيديوهات
الان الرمال الجنوبي صدر منه فيديوهات
الان دخلت هذه القوات الى مناطق محدده
وجرى التعامل معها والان يعني ننتظر وصول
فيديوهات انما الاخبار الاوليه تم تدمير
دبابات تم تدمير ناقلات جند وتم استهداف
والقضاء على 15 ما دلاله هذا الموضوع
تحديدا هو شده المعارك يعني في الشمال
يفترض انها انتهت الى حد كبير لا ما هو
تحدثنا وزير الدفاع قال بانه تم تفكيك
الاطر التنظيميه لكتاب القسام رد عليه
رئيس الاركان هليفي وقال
لا لا تزال لديها قوه و وستعيد تنظيمها
مما يجبرنا على عمليه موسعه ثم جاء وزير
الدفاع وقال القضاء على جيوب حماس ليس
بالامر الممكن والسهل اذا هناك تضارب في
التصريحات الان دخلت هذه القوات متى لماذا
تدخل تدخل توفر معلومات عن وجود رهائن
توفر معلومات عن شبكه انفاق ظهور مقاتلين
فوق سطح الارض الان يدخل هذا هذا هذا
الدخول هو مطلب للمقاومه هو مطلب للمقاومه
المقاومه تستطيع ايقاع الضرر بجيش
الاحتلال من مسافه الصفر وبالتالي هي الان
تجد الفرصه وجرى ما جرى نعم لدينا نحو
دقيقه ونصف او شيء من هذا النحو بالنسبه
للجنوب والحديث عن القضاء على ثلاثه كتائب
من القوه الاساسيه للمقاومه من كتاب
القسام في الجنوب هذا ما يقوله الاسرائيلي
هذا ما يقوله يعني وانا هنا اعطف ال على
ما تحدثنا به قبل قليل قالوا تم تفكيك
كتائب الشمال وتم اعاده
بنائها لوائين لواء غزه لواء الشمال من 12
كتيبه الكتيبه بين 850 و1250 فاذا الذي
قال تحدث عن الشمال انه فكك ودمر 700 منصه
اطلاق ليتحدث عن خان يونس اللواء فايز
الدويري الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي شكرا
جزيلا لك وشكرا لسلام خضر التي كانت معنا
الخارطه التفاعليه ختام هذه النافذه
العسكريه الخاصه بحرب اسرائيل على غزه